in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you believe make up a highly
successful recruitment concern and in
today's market I like when you say
today's market because like you said 13
years in the industry I think my
perception uh and I'm sure other people
in my position would say yeah hard work
you know all those things great uh
communication skills they're standard
they need to be there for me it would be
commercial awareness I think people when
they're switched on they're curious
commercially to know what's happening in
the market I think that's a good sign of
a recruiter in the making accountability
is big given how recruitment is done
today the emphasis on yields dph what is
the business doing from a profitability
perspective I think if people feel
accountable they perform better I.E they
know what their goals and targets are so
they're accountable towards them another
thing I've definitely heard this on one
of your podcasts and I thought about it
that's actually yeah pretty much what we
look for as well people who are moldable
people who are willing to try different
things all of those traits in my opinion
I think yeah that you're you're set for
a good recruitment career if you've got
that in locker the recruitment mentors
podcast is proudly sponsored by VIN
cherry and the award-winning Source
breaker